She's an actor, producer and director.
She's an entrepreneur and host,
she's mom to Frankie and Olive,
Drew Barrymore, this is your life.
Acting before she could even walk,
Ms. Barrymore has since appeared in almost 100 movies,
TV shows, and mini series.
From that adorable shriek in E.T.
(shrieking)
We all remember that,
to a horrified scream,
she's been a bad girl,
Never Been Kissed and gone on 50 First Dates.
She's still the youngest person ever
to host Saturday Night Live
while her turn as Little Edie in Grey Gardens
earned her a Golden Globe in 2010.
On the other side of the camera
she started her own production company
when she was just 19 years old
and has since produced over a dozen films,
including Charlie's Angels,
where the combined box office earnings over $2 billion,
that's billion with a B.
But, that's not all.
For over a decade she spearheaded an entrepreneurial empire,
that includes a home line, eye wear,
hair tools, kitchenware
and an award-winning makeup brand, that's Flower Beauty.
Her signature smile graces the cover of countless magazines
and if you follow her on social media
you get a welcoming glimpse into her real life,
cooking, she cooks, kids and all.
And now in her latest chapter of life
as talk show host,
she brings her brand of sunshine to the world day after day.
She's a bright light in the dark,
a breath of fresh air
and eternal optimist
and one wild flower.
She is Drew Barrymore.
happy birthday Drew.
That was nice, God Drew Barrymore done a lot y'all.
(upbeat music)